- Right when I got back from
That's what my wife said,
she said I was a hot mess.
I didn't want to
reintegrate into society.
I couldn't be in
crowded places anymore.
It made me really twitchy.
I hated going to work again.
Rachel?
That's what really made
me realize how much
I miss you and miss the family.
I think I'm healed now.
I think this healed me.
[crying]
I didn't even think of that.
I think this did heal me.
I think this trip healed me.
I was such a mess
after Vancouver Island.
I just didn't want life at all.
I didn't want anything.
Now, I want it all.
I want it back again.
Since I've been
here, I've realized I
truly deep down need my family.
It's not a superficial need.
I need my family to survive.
But I'm conflicted because
I know I could stay longer.
It would be torture
staying longer.
I want to go home.
I miss my family.
I miss the creature
comforts in life.
I'm done.
[beep sound]
Hello, this is Larry.
I'm ready for you guys
to come get me, man.
[truck approaching]
Mongolia kind of slapped
me upside the head
and said, listen, you little
moron, you got a good job,
you got an awesome wife,
you have fantastic kids,
just stop moping
around and enjoy life.
I have just enjoyed
the experience so
much more than I did
on Vancouver Island
and now I'm ready to go home.
And I've got fantastic
people in my life
that I want to keep
close to and I don't
want to leave them ever again.
And that's what I
learned out here.
I'm going to remember
what it's like to starve.
what it's like to not
be able to talk to your
friends or talk to you wife.
But I'm also going to
remember the blue sky,
the ice crystals on the trees.
I'm going to remember
my fishing pole
and how I caught a
lot of fish on that.
I've gotten everything out
of this experience I can get.
I had the most pleasure, the
most discomfort that helped
teach myself these lessons.
Vancouver Island broke me down
to just a shell of a person.
This time I am leaving
on my own terms.
It's OK to know
your limitations.
And it's OK, I don't have
to push myself as hard as I
pushed myself my entire life.
I'm starting to realize that.